hi this is just going to be a very small
update video in which I'm actually going
to talk about uh things that I've been
doing lately and mainly also why I
haven't been uploading too many videos
this week it's because of some very
awesome things first of all I've got a
new pc and it's custom built and awesome
video card so Graphics gonna be a lot
better from now on and also you might be
able to tell that my voice is just
sounds a bit better overall and that's
because I got a new microphone well I
got a microphone I I didn't really have
a microphone before I just used my
headset so that is really cool so that
means that in general the quality of my
videos is going to be better but I
didn't do too much this week because uh
I just had to get around
um actually well my dad actually did
most of the work building the PC because
I was doing it even thought I could
actually do it myself but that didn't
turn out to work like that but yeah and
then came the fact that my let's play
park is still not opening in roller
coaster 3 it's still constantly crashes
for some reason I've got Silver City to
work on it and most of the projects that
I'm working on but for some reason the
park just doesn't want to work and it
keeps on crashing every time I open it
and move around so I still really want
to fix that but regardless of that I am
actually going to
um well confirm this at this point the
let's play of rollercoaster 3 is going
to be changed completely because I kind
of want to step away from the idea of
building one park and making a let's
play of that and would rather focus on
all of the projects that I'm doing
because at the moment I am doing so many
projects in roller coaster 3 yet I'm
only recording that one park and then
the Silver City of course and the
tutorial but there's much more of course
I didn't record me building credits but
I didn't record me building real gun Etc
so I would like to focus on that aspect
of things as well and kind of show you
all of the coasters that I'm working on
and I also feel that this is actually a
way for me to actually record a lot more
often because I can do that because I
have a new pc and it's not as crappy as
my old laptop and of course it's also
really awesome because it means that I
can make more videos though I'm already
making plenty of videos I'm not going to
make too much more but yeah that's
pretty much it not that so I am actually
doing loads of experimenting
because even though I've got this mic
and I've even got a pop filter on it I
do I do kind of see even on the audio
readout that I'm still getting some
slight pops on it so you might want to
actually mess around with that and also
of course I need to get that let's play
part to work and I need to get all of my
old Custom Scenery back and all of the
tracked rides and actually work on my
Custom Scenery on my new pc as well and
install everything that I need to have
to make videos so but yeah that does
mean actually that I'm going to do a lot
more experimental stuff in the future
but not quite as many videos right now
because I'm kind of busy transitioning
from my laptop and actually doing things
on my PC so now you kind of know the
situation so that was the small little
update video and I'm actually going to
record a Silver City video right now so
bye